greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by my [ __ ] bookie let me
tell you something it's n-c-double-a
March Madness is here and it's time to
bet with the best at my bookie let me
they even grandmother's fill out
brackets so place your bets with my
bookie now before you miss out what
we're gonna do is this my bookie will
match your deposit with the 50% bonus up
to $1,000 right now getting ready for
March Madness use promo code Church CH
you are CH to activate the offer visit
my bookie dot AG today
listen you play you win you get paid
only at my bookie dot AG the church is
also brought to you by zip recruiter
listen you know it's the hire some money
you have any idea it's hard to find
qualified candidates it takes a long
time and it's too many applicants and
with zip recruiter that makes it a lot
easier let me tell you you're trying to
do your job you're trying to do your job
and also now you gotta stop and hire and
looking resumes and talk to people and
creepy people come in your office you
need that until it's over today we're
gonna make this nice and easy
zip recruiter sends you your job to over
a hundred of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there with
that powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find the people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job that's it and right now the
church family can try zip recruiter for
free that's right free at zip recruited
comm slash Church again that slip
recruiter comms last Church CH you are
CH zip recruiter comm slash Church it's
Monday the 11th of March kick this
[ __ ] mule league what's up you
bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here and
Lisa a T aka the Christ killer aka the
flying Jew aka I'm sick I'm a prank I
don't know what the [ __ ] you talk of the
money way I want to thank the Houston
improv and the people that came to the
shows they were great five sold-out
shows fantastic you know it's so weird
when I was down
Thursday night a lady came up to me took
a picture and showed me a picture of me
and Joe Rogan Joe Rogan had hair at the
time he it was [ __ ] the mood kids
it had to be 1999 98 2000 around there
and I looked at the picture you know I
was coked up I was still [ __ ] doing
drugs and whatnot when I looked at
that's the first thing I know but I also
noticed that Jesus Christ I had been
going to Houston for that [ __ ] long
that must be awesome it's you know I've
been going to Houston since 97 when
Houston Livestock was the hottest club
in the country anyway like Joey what
does that mean there was a couple clubs
in the area in Houston at the time but
they attracted this weird you had to
give it to mark Babbitt he knew how to
book a club and where the location was
the people that would come and it was
called inside the loop and it was gray
whatever Wes gray whatever the [ __ ] and
it was just a great neighborhood and it
was a different time you know Bill Hicks
it started there Candace and that
started there you know there was a dry
cleaner across the street when they
banned Kennison he put himself on a
cross across the street from the club
that was like a legends my spot you know
it was just such a legendary place to go
to because of what had been there before
you and like I cut my [ __ ] teeth in
that room you know and the last stop was
the last stop and they moved and this
which donors and there was a nightmare
but the people of Houston was still
there they were still comedy fans it's
like Portland has come along over the
years and Charlotte and all these you
call these clubs and it's exciting
people excited to see comedy we're 15
years ago in that area comedy was just
breaking through now people are had
people listen to podcast people know
what time is going on but Houston this
weekend was it to a complete different
level and I just wanted to thank you
guys as usual I want the [ __ ] Papa
dose and what the papacito's a nice
young lady from Pasadena left me
coupon for Chuy's I didn't get to use it
this time but I'll use it in May when I
go back to Dallas and [ __ ] San
Antonio May 3rd and 4th I'm in Dallas
and then the 4th I'm in San Antonio but
we'll get there that [ __ ] later for the
last three weeks I've avoided a topic on
this show for a reason this podcast is
not a platform to drag a dog in here
onion I never want to drag a dog in here
honey especially in a [ __ ] Monday but
we got to get the elephant out of the
[ __ ] room between us
February 22nd I had I got up that
morning and I went to lift and I played
with the baby and then I took the baby
to school when I went to left and I I
was going to Las Vegas for Kate and we
got the Burbank and Kate flew out before
me and as I was sitting down on the
[ __ ] plane I mean the plane I didn't
take it off yet and people were still
boarding if you ever flown in and out of
Burbank you could they let you walk in
through the back of the plane so my most
[ __ ] Momo's were walking through the
front I just walked through the back of
the plane and take a seat in the back
because when you get to Vegas you're
gonna have to wait for luggage anyway
and it's always a [ __ ] long walk so
who gives a [ __ ] where you sit on a
Southwest flight so I sat down and two
minutes into that I sit down the phone
rings and it's my brother Steve Simone
and he goes did you hear the bad news
and I don't know he goes you know Brody
was found this morning on himself guys
it was like a kick to the stomach on the
plane this couple got I don't if you've
been put on a plane from Burbank to
Vegas they even wrote a movie about it a
TV show last year about Vegas it's a
crazy flight the reason why it's so
crazy it's is people are excited people
are excited to go to [ __ ] Vegas and
every time I get on one of those planes
like the one time they [ __ ] the cops
had to come on the plane and take ten
kids off there's always drama on those
flights these are all these people that
were ready to go and Here I am sitting
in the edge seat crying like crying like
bawling and I'm trying to wipe the tears
and make-believe like I got something in
my eyes and I had to get up and go and
get tissues and the thing
sat back down and when I landed in Vegas
you know the Fallen [ __ ] goes off you
had six messages and every message was
worse and you know this is supposed to
be exciting night to me I was on [ __ ]
the the strip on Sun you know in Las
Vegas and in the car land thinking about
is this [ __ ] kid then you know he
killed himself and he was just on the
show a couple weeks earlier and he spoke
about getting off the medication and
then know how to feel and then you know
I got to the hotel and Kate was crying
because Kate was working with me that
weekend so I I took Kate we ate dinner
together and I hung out with her as much
as I could and I had a job to do I had a
[ __ ] job to do I felt like [ __ ] but I
had a job to do I don't know if you guys
know this I suffer from here infections
I have to have to take a shower with
earplugs in because the water gets in my
ear and then when I fly I get infections
and [ __ ] so I gotta put the [ __ ]
things in my ear so Kate left and the
show was gonna start at 8:00 and you
know when I go to Vegas it's all about
the shower the shower is always huge and
the [ __ ] sweet I love taking a shower
cuz you could sit down and think and I
take a couple of hips off the vapor pen
I didn't smoke pot at all that day by
the way I smoked I think I smoked in the
morning but before I took the baby to
school like when I get up in the morning
I wish to smoke but I didn't smoke the
rest of the day I didn't want to leave
my hotel room I felt so bad when I was
in Vegas so I hit the vapor pen I put
the plugs away no in the shower and
while I was in the shower and the water
was hitting me and I was sitting there I
thought about Brody's last 10 minutes
like what the [ __ ] was he doing you know
like what was he thinking what was he
feeling and all of a sudden my heart
started racing you know I broke down a
little bit emotionally in the shower you
know I started seeing him as a kid you
know I still remember having the
conversation with him and Seattle about
him moving to New York because
obviously he was just distinctively
different than everybody else
and New York would really accept him the
way they accepted him Mitch Hedberg you
know so I had this little breakdown I
got out of the shower I wiped my face
and you know had a job to do guys
I had a [ __ ] job to do so I put it in
the back burner like I usually do with
everything when it comes to that type of
stuff emotions and I you know did the
show and we tried to keep it together we
hate afterwards her myself
Brent my instructor over at subconscious
we ate some late night dinner we have
not talked to so I never really I did
what I did as a child when my mother
died I kept people around so the pain
wouldn't be around and I waited till I
got nice and tired and I asked him to
leave when I went to sleep and then the
next morning I had to get up and get on
a plane and rush and so the whole time I
was avoiding the pain I was avoiding
dealing with Brody's death we went to
Tucson and my buddy's showing up cat
Vella and the show was great and the
people were great and the [ __ ] food
was great the top was great so it wasn't
till the next day that's Sunday when I
got off the plane when I was fronting
with it I spoke to Josh wolf and Joshua
was very close to brought him it was
Josh go fool introduced me to brownie
and I gets hear it in his voice so it
was a toll on him now I could have gone
on Twitter you know Twitter was [ __ ]
filled with Brody stuff you couldn't
even open it up I tried opening it up
that Saturday on my phone cuz when I'm
on the road I don't take the computer I
have the iPad doesn't have Facebook on
it or Twitter I only have Twitter on my
phone I don't have no apps on my iPad
only writing and like HBO go
Netflix [ __ ] like that I have a writing
act that's all I want to do on the road
so well I did open up Twitter I saw
everybody was on there and I live my
life to [ __ ] be different I don't
know about you guys I don't want to be
like everybody [ __ ] else you know I'm
saying yeah
and I strive to do this every day you
know I was telling Lee that when I went
to my mother's funeral
I learned the people cried the loudest
didn't talk to me after my mother died
the people didn't say [ __ ]
we're the people who came to her after
my mother died so I learned to his
[ __ ] and who was not
that's not a reason why I didn't I
didn't tweet because I didn't want to go
that you know I just didn't want to go
there I got a couple emails from people
and a couple twits you know on my DM and
people going near you haven't written on
about Brody what does that matter what
is that well cuz I didn't write nothing
doesn't mean I didn't love the kid where
what did we [ __ ] become why don't we
[ __ ] become them we don't have to you
know show our solidarity we don't care
about this kid I just didn't want to
deal with the guys I didn't want to deal
with that that in that level I didn't
even want to mention on the podcast I
didn't want them my Twitter feed I
didn't wanted my Facebook feed I wanted
to feel it in my heart I didn't want to
write anything down that I would regret
later that was number one number one if
you know anything about [ __ ] death
especially the way it happened here
listen when Chris Cornell died that
bothered me when people commit suicide
yes if you have any empathy at all it
bothered me this is my backyard this was
a friend of mine who sat across from me
in his chair a month earlier and told us
as the church family us that he was fine
I'm alive and kick'n and he was off the
medication and blah blah blah blah but
that's not the point here the point here
that there's different phases of
grieving there's the sad phase then you
get angry and then you [ __ ] get sad
and then you get frustrated
you know all I kept thinking about was
Brody's
last 10 minutes and until I figured out
what he went through what he felt like
those last 10 minutes which I never know
and I'll never don't want to know I'll
never want to know what those last 10
minutes of you know I feel like when
you're getting ready to do something
that and your mind takes over everything
and lies to you because as you can see
and as I know for a [ __ ] fact now
there are people still walking around
shell-shocked not tonight I had to do
something that I [ __ ] hate doing I
have to go to the Comi store and get up
in front of people and give some some
[ __ ] speech about you know a story
about Brody listen man this is so much
in my backyard and you guys know me then
when it comes to Brody right now I don't
have no [ __ ] stories like all I am is
a search of why this kid would do this
when they [ __ ] loved him down there
they loved him at that Comedy Store they
loved me was father's store he was who I
mean mitts he made him you know Mitzi
[ __ ] put him on he was one of those
guys that like Don Barris you're a part
of the [ __ ] story you will be apart
forever
but again nobody really knows nothing
until you lose something you know
tonight I gotta go down there and I
gotta talk him before and I don't even
know what the [ __ ] to say like I don't
know what the [ __ ] to say I haven't
processed his death yet this is my
weakness in life you're my weakness is
death because every time somebody dies
I'm close to I drag the other 15 people
that died through it so too right now
all I have in my mind is that rayo I
have my mother I have Anthony Bolzano on
my mind I have Dominick special on my
mind I had all those shitty wakes I went
to and couldn't figure out why this
person is in a [ __ ] casket that's
what I drag with me I couldn't figure
out at that early age in the eighth
grade why this [ __ ] 13 year old kid
that never did nothin to nobody was in a
[ __ ] casket then a year later I had
to look at my mother and think about why
God would take away somebody's mother
then a year later I had a look at that
same [ __ ] castle my buddy Dominic
speciality and that did something to me
that did something to me before the age
of 18
it's like going to Vietnam and seeing
your son in your platoon dying I mean I
didn't see Anthony get hit by a car I
was
there when dominant drowned you know I
was there to find my mother but that's
what happens I drag all that [ __ ] so for
a few days
like right now I can feel my blood
pressure going I'm just talking about it
because I drag all that [ __ ] I dragged
that regular wood in there I dragged
this girl in high school that I just
thought about today that she was good
friends with a friend of mine and Shanna
walk with me she died my senior year and
a car accident she got trapped in
between the [ __ ] tree and a parka who
the [ __ ] knows
but I think about all these people
that's why every Monday today I [ __ ]
go to my you know when I wake up in the
morning on Mondays I got did this
morning I'll go to the alter my spirit
all time I changed the water and I light
a candle to give all those spirits like
just to let them know I'm taking them I
now Brody you know we lost Marilyn
Martinez we lost Martinez his husband
we lost Freddy so no since I've been at
The Comedy Store it's a part of life but
this one hits a lot more this one hurts
and stings a lot more because it's the
first time a friend of mine that close
has taken his [ __ ] life whatever I've
had other friends who have tried to take
that life but none of this one it hurts
it bothers me like I said I wanted to
not put this on the podcast but since
we're doing the memorial today I mean
they're closing the Comedy Store they're
going full boat tonight III you know
four days I thought about [ __ ]
mysteriously getting sick today because
I didn't want to go down there and talk
but I have to come on an age now that I
have to stop thinking this way I have to
go down there like I didn't go to
midsi's I didn't go to Ralphie's you
know what my buddy Jimmy Buerkle died I
didn't go to his there were reasons
behind I could have gotten on a plane
and gone tubercles and got up there and
talked and I just don't like dealing
with that type of [ __ ] I still have
Burkle's number in my phone
I started Ralphie's number in my phone I
still have Brody's number in my phone I
don't like dealing with it you know
that's where my weakness is when it
comes to death
I doubt PUD enough I'm on the mood to
[ __ ] deal with it and then I'm
sitting there thinking about this
medication problem we have now in this
[ __ ] country you know it's not only
the opiate problem these people's minds
why the [ __ ] would somebody like Chris
Cornell do a show and then go to his
[ __ ] room and hang himself III just
don't understand it
I understand CTE I understand all these
things but again Joey you haven't been
there you don't know what depression is
you know what between us as a family
I've had bouts with it now from what
I've read about after Brody I've had
bouts with it but being from the cut
that I am I can't let it overtake me
because I don't have the time you know I
didn't I never really had the time to
get gold haha I think I went through a
bout of depression Mike in 84 and I also
went through about a depression in 2006
that that ignited my drug consumption
which made me [ __ ] quit which is why
the reason I'm still here today because
I've been clean 11 years from all those
type of [ __ ] drugs but that
depression after a long is yard that
nothing happened I felt like all the key
is a Comley all [ __ ] 15 years of
calmly and now I hit the movie I'm
supposed to hit and nothing happened and
I went into a funk but I gotta be honest
II at no moment but I think I've taken
my life so it wasn't really a depression
like most people [ __ ] go through you
know from now to the day they put me in
my casket I'm gonna wonder about Brody's
last 10 minutes like his last 10 minutes
like what his mind told him so now I
gotta think of it from two [ __ ]
dynamics now my wife goes to bed at 8:30
all other nights but the baby goes to
bed at 8:30
some nights my one who stays up till
9:30 sometimes she's tied she goes to
bed at 9:00
and sometimes I sit there for 2 hours at
night and I watch a little TV and I make
a few notes and I try to write a
sentence here when I try to write a tag
to a joke there I listen to music I
smoke a little bit of the pipe but now
I'm starting to get scared if one night
my mind's gonna play a trick on me I and
I obviously have no idea I think the
difference is is that for Brodie to seem
like he he didn't get the breaks between
the depression went to me if I had to
guess it was that it was just it finally
got to be too much look it's not like
it's all year when went through periods
of happiness I think that's what would
get you you know what was he lying to us
you know for starters let's put our
[ __ ] cards on the table here I'm the
type of guy that there's nobody that's
that nice you know people who are too
nice always make me [ __ ] nervous so
well if somebody comes up to me and
they're telling me about positivity and
this and this and this
there's to a point that I [ __ ] shut
up shut down like I really do I like
it's too much [ __ ] talking just don't
show me the positive don't don't tell me
about the positive
show me the positive you know so
somebody tweeted me last week over the
last couple of weeks people have been
tweeting me and I guess you know they've
been gone back and listening to all the
Brody's appearances on it on the show
primarily the last one and a lot of
people have said what the [ __ ] didn't
you know he was off the medication now
again I don't know the mind of a
depressed person you know listen for me
for me I gotta tell you guys something
calmly chain saved my life calmly saved
my life
calmly saved my life why because finally
my life had purpose and I fell in love
with something
and today I sit here and I'm very happy
and very fortunate and I fell in love
with something so much that all those
years you know I have friends I talked
to some of you guys you know a lot of
you guys are young and you're struggling
well guess what you're gonna [ __ ]
struggle you're gonna struggle that's
the age of you're at and you think that
you're never gonna get out of that
[ __ ] hole or you're never gonna get
out of that position and I Got News for
You you're wrong if you believe and if
you fall in love with something if you
fall in love with something so deep and
you believe in it it will give you the
dividend so in my mind he was doing
great guys guys he was doing great
yeah but Joey he's not Sebastian he
didn't solve for shows the mess I
thought that that that doesn't that he
was doing great okay let me tell you
something from 2000 to 2005 98 to 2005 I
had a very hard time in this town what
what hard time did you have joy
rejection rejection I didn't go to
Montreal I was never part of the [ __ ]
Rat Pack there's nothing there's nothing
improv in the country that has my
portrait on the [ __ ] wall I learned
to live with it it wasn't my quality I
didn't know what it was did I quit no I
didn't quit I kept doing it I liked it
right and I kept doing it and I'd pop a
little TV show there then pop a little
TV show there and still nobody ever
invited me to calmly nothing nothing
that nothing you look at all nobody
[ __ ] talk to me but Joe Rogan talked
to me
Ari Shaffir talk to me red band talk to
me Duncan talk to me you know Paul
Mooney talked to me and he Griffin
talked to me and in my world where I
come from [ __ ] that was worth more than
or any of that [ __ ] that was worth more
than any of that [ __ ] bringing up Chris
Rock in the main room Christmas week and
him [ __ ] turning around and talking
about me on stage that why you
[ __ ] are watching all these big
names you better watch this
the [ __ ] my wife who was my wife now
at that time was my girlfriend I
remember her coming home and going did
you but Chris Rock said find you tonight
that everybody's looking at the wrong
comics they should be watching you that
meant more to me than a [ __ ] Academy
Award if you listen that meant at that
time that night I couldn't even do coke
that man I was so excited I could even
[ __ ] sleep that Chris Rock was
talking about me so forgot like me
calmly saved my life because I never
really had nothing else I never really
had nothing else that I was even I was
good at [ __ ] but I didn't want to put
the work in I didn't want to put the
work in calmly the work was easy for me
it was very easy for me it was very uh
it came naturally I understood what my
[ __ ] I had to do so this whole time I'm
thinking that Brody's the same guy I am
I'm thinking that wait a second we're
out of the [ __ ] weeds here we're at
the store we're getting spots and he was
captain midnight at the [ __ ] store
you know was Captain midnight Sam
Kennison Sam Kinison had that [ __ ] that
he went up a Midland brownie was Captain
midnight I'm not even captain midnight I
don't want to be [ __ ] captain
midnight Brody was captain midnight
that's how you know you Paul Mooney was
captain midnight that's who one up at
midnight special [ __ ] savages go up
at midnight they want to go up at midday
request to go up at midnight so I
thought he had something there's no way
listen in my darkest moments when I was
in the hotel with $6 I had a show that
night that's all that mattered to me
I had a [ __ ] show that night and then
three or four hours even though I was
broke nothing was going on I didn't have
a girlfriend I was living out of boxes I
had a show tonight and in my world
that's all that matter of daily I if I
had a show it had a way to snort a
couple [ __ ] lines are you kidding me
and I can either Subway sandwich your
veggie and cheese I'm good to go
I'm in love with Carly
so I thought when Brody came in here
this last time he looked good
he acted normal I was around for his
first bout when Zach Galifianakis had a
call around the police arrested him and
they took him to the [ __ ] mental
health place for a couple days and he
was observation and he came out and he
was like I'm back he had a he had a new
lease on life so he pulled the wool over
my eyes
that's another complete part of the
grief program it's like the guy that you
talked to and tells you at 7 o'clock at
night that he's fine he's been going to
a meetings and then the next day you
realized he [ __ ] shot a hot [ __ ]
load and now he's dead wait a second I
saw him last night at 7 o'clock and he
told me he was just coming back on her
[ __ ] to a meeting that's the same way
this took us that's the same way this
took me what cuz you said you told me a
couple weeks ago that you you you were
thinking about his last 10 minutes and
that really struck me like a that's a
dark place to go even just for you like
most people get sad cuz he's out there
and well I wish I could help but like
that's a that's a really dark place to
go is the last 10 minutes but why do you
think why do you think that I came to
your mind because I wanted to know what
was in his mind those last 10 minutes
while he was tying a rope or figuring
out where to throw the rope over to hang
himself or putting the noose over his
neck and pulling it on it to see if it
was on tight like where his mind went
like where his mind went and and it was
funny because that - the night or the
night after Brody so I got the news from
Steve Simone I was watching FX and
concussion was
which will smith it's a football movie
about a doctor who discovers CTE in
Pittsburgh with all the Pittsburgh
Steelers and stuff like that and you
know jr. seiya
was fine he was fine that morning or
something he will be with his daughter I
don't know and then he went and shot
himself you know I want to know where it
what is he was thinking his last 10
minutes you know the last 10 minutes for
Brody Stephens I don't know if he was at
the store the night he hung himself
I don't know if he had come home from
the store I don't know if he had gotten
bad news you know some people said it
was the comments that people had made a
bother special
I think Brody had thicker skin than that
I think that Brody had thicker skin than
that so the last ten minutes of his life
listen okay couple weeks ago mrs. dinner
table of my wife and we're talking about
[ __ ] her going back to Nashville for
uh Easter week to some [ __ ] we were just
looking around the calendar to see when
it was the best week for her to go and
was she my wife does everything on our
[ __ ] phones all right there to the
table she goes well she goes to plane
tickets of this much money I think there
was 676 for her and the baby to go back
each and she goes if I wait till this
time they go down a 440 or something
like that it wasn't really a big deal
you know I understand the plane industry
I understand the plane tickets and now
you know how land is hot
Nashville's hot so they charge you like
an extra $1 to go to [ __ ] Nashville
an American or you know Southwest goes
there but the amount that they wanted in
April was [ __ ] a lot they wanted a
lot for a regular [ __ ] ticket to
Nashville okay be my wife disgusted and
after 10 minutes we came to the
conclusion like normal people that we
weren't gonna go someone
minutes we decided that we weren't gonna
go that was a decision that we made let
me break it down more for you guys
especially men don't listen to this
podcast you ever go home with three
beers in you and you start calling
chicks to come over and you start
calling them and calling and calling
them and one chick is 45 minutes away
and the other girl has to get ready and
the other girl won't come over unless
you have cocaine sand I gotta call you a
drug dealer but he's at a bar and all of
a sudden you just take your dick out
jerk-off and you go to bed and nothing
[ __ ] happened you know that's the
same thing I thought about like let's
say he got home he took the noose he
[ __ ] made it but he looked at it
after a minute you go
what was I what am I thinking and you
throw the [ __ ] loose under the bed
and hope not money's never sees it
that's why I say his last 10 minutes you
know how many times that I [ __ ] I
used to be cooked up at 3 in the morning
and I'd be [ __ ] coked up I look in
the mirror my jaw would be going my eyes
would be glassy and I would start
walking down stairs to get in the car to
go over to pick up coke from somebody
and I had common sense so I know I
couldn't get a DUI and I know for a fact
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] on it but if I'm
coked up and a cop pulls me over I will
fall apart at the seams you guys know
even though I was a junkie [ __ ] I would
sit I would go back upstairs and figure
out a way and I didn't have to get in
the car so I could still get coke even
if I had to pay the guy an extra 10
bucks before over anything you know I
would do it that's what I'm trying to
say to you his last 10 minutes even if
he thought about it for nine minutes and
the last minute he goes [ __ ] this what
am i [ __ ] thinking that's why I said
the last 10 minutes because this just
didn't listen
Chris Cornell did a [ __ ] show got off
the got off the stage called his wife
she felt his voice was a little his tone
wuzzle he was slurring his words she
called the security guard to check on
him and he had hung himself so what was
Chris Cornell's last ten minutes like he
just got off the phone with his wife
what do you tell your wife when you have
kids ain't honey I love you just
finished the show it was great I'm gonna
go upstairs and maybe get a late-night
bite to eat and I'll call you in the
morning when I wake up don't forget the
time my daughter don't forget to tell
whatever my daughter's name is mercy
have a good day at school don't forget
to tell my son that I love him okay you
say those things so now in between that
phone call and going up to his hotel
room whether this brain snap and tell
him to get a belt and hang himself where
that's that that's the question that I
have what happened on the way up now one
thing that people have been saying at
the comedy stories is that he went off
his medications and then he went back on
and that could be something you know
it's like what's going on now in America
that people do heroin and then you get
off the heroin and then you go back on
the heroin but you do the same man you
were doing and your tolerance went down
so it's a hot needle now you die is the
medication work the same way
oh you're not supposed to go cold turkey
let's tell you that's a very serious
thing so once you're on that medication
you're on that medication forever and
they have to keep working and and they
can get you off of it but it's supposed
to be like a multi-week process so isn't
it better if we just don't go on the
medication there's this medication this
necklace all I hear about this like they
plant a dear friend of mine called me
about six months ago and said they
prescribed slow loft but when you see
the commercial for Zoloft they think
it's an antidepressant it tells you
you're gonna have suicidal feelings and
suicidal thoughts
you know the pill did not paint
cigarettes like if you want to get off
cigarettes
tranquil whatever the [ __ ] it is that
Ray Leona does they tell you you're
gonna get suicidal tendencies I don't
know if you have the smoked cigarettes
and you quit you think about suicide on
its own you don't need to [ __ ] tell
the gate you that when you quit smoking
and you do those first three [ __ ]
days you think about [ __ ] putting the
bowl in your [ __ ] head
it's the worst feeling in the goddamn
world but you know what my point is is
why would they prescribe this medication
if has suicidal tendencies if it even
brings you to that these are the
questions that I have and I'm not a
doctor and yeah I've looked into a
couple things even before Brodie died
even before Brody's death you know I
would stay up late look at the internet
some nights about depression you know
that they did a show about the dark side
of comedy on seeing it and it had me
[ __ ] going when Robin Williams died I
wasn't personal friends with Robin
Williams I had met him once at the
improv and I saw more than at the Comedy
Store I didn't know him personally so
yes it affected me because I have the
mind of a comic and you're telling me
that this is successful susceptible
amongst comics when I watch that Dark
Side economy you know and the dark side
is depression that's what they all kept
talking about was depression so you know
for now and my older age this is what I
worry about like this really scares me
that what happens to me now between 9:00
and 11:00 at night when I'm on 9:30 to
11:00 when I'm home by myself and my
mind goes into these places that and my
mind never goes into weird places I
never let my mind I told you guys
honestly the truth I thought about
suicide two times once it was after my
mother died and I think the other time
now I think that was after my mother
died and once when I was going through
that cocaine thing and I was homeless in
83 84 I was really putting myself in a
rut I didn't know where I was gonna go
and I didn't know and I went to bed
thinking about Joe
I'm off a bridge but I wish I'd have the
balls to saw I never [ __ ] did the
closest I came to feeling suicidal was
that Christmas holiday of 79 that was
the closest because the pain was over
Barry but obviously it wasn't that
overbearing at that age compared to what
Brody was going through you know I
really wanted to do this podcast for the
last couple of weeks but I wanted to be
prepared I wanted to be prepared
emotionally I didn't want to bring a
comedian here and break down a life a
Brody and show us crying that's not what
I wanted to show you people today I just
wanted to talk to you about those last
10 minutes and if you ever go there I
want you to know that seriously
seriously
you have [ __ ] options okay you don't
want to call a suicide hotline never my
buddy one time he was throwing quote it
was long coke and he talked okay as we
were snorting the coke we were only
going on a two-day binge and was sitting
around a table and he's staring at the
phone I read the couple of minutes and
he kept saying under his breath lord
please help me lord please help me kept
mom like he gonna actually saying he
kept saying lord please help me lord
please help me can even do another one
there was a guy that every time we come
in the room he go to telethon
and he'd open up a package it was like
maybe two or three grams of coke and he
put it on the table I forget what the
guy's name was this guy did ten times
that night and we were six of us sitting
around the table we were to the point we
weren't even talking to each other
we were just staring at each other or
everybody was sweating and everybody
smelled bad there was checks in the
living room we couldn't even talk to
them we were so [ __ ] up and Roger kept
looking at the phone and finally he just
gets up out of his chair grabs a phone
and those [ __ ] coke
in a cocaine hotline they had a cocaine
hotline in 83 all right and he called it
he's a cocaine Outland I can't stop
smoking and the way he said call me back
when he stops doing and he went off on
it what the [ __ ] do I need your phone
when I stopped thought by that time I'll
be sleeping I don't need you so I'm not
talking about suicide hotline
there are people you could call but
listen the people around you other
people then you have to call just one
person it's got to be the most
embarrassing [ __ ] call in the world
for somebody I can't even imagine being
there but if it saves her life that's
all that matters to me guys what the
[ __ ] your friends therefore see again
this is the fourth level of greenery
there's so many levels to grieving with
mother's gonna be dead 40 [ __ ] years
this November and at the end of the day
when the baby's sleeping and my wife
isn't bad I just got back from the
comedy store and I stopped and yum yum
donuts to get a bran muffin at the end
of the day I always think about my mom I
think about you know what the [ __ ]
happened like I wish she could be around
to see my [ __ ] daughter so the
grieving process never ends because it
comes in different levels like I said
the first its angular then it's pain
then it's questions done frustration
then you get pissed at the person like
right now I'm in the phase
that I still feel sad over Brody did but
I guaranteed in about eight months I'm
gonna be a little [ __ ] pissed off
somebody's gonna come in here and we're
gonna be doing a podcast so I'm gonna
bring up his name and I'm gonna say
something [ __ ] up because that's what
happens you go through different levels
you know at first I was in shock or my
mother died and then I'm like how the
[ __ ] could she take care of herself well
she knew she had a [ __ ] kid and then
you just realized that won't ever you
have an expiration date my friend how
you go is I don't know how will you go
what we all have an expiration day so
you go through that [ __ ] part of it I
feel bad for Brody's family I feel bad
for Brody's immediate family which is us
at the Comedy Store
my suggestion let me talk to Steve
Simone about this is that we do a big
benefit show and we call it the Brody
Stephens you know whatever fund I don't
want to give it a [ __ ] name or
something and I'd like to get a
psychiatrist that's well-known in the
Hollywood area and if a comic needs to
talk to somebody we could dip into that
fund they could build a Comedy Store and
the fund could pay for a therapy session
or two or three or four whatever is
needed at the time you know that's the
only way we're gonna stop this [ __ ] from
happening listen you guys know my
reputation but I check in with people I
also try to check him with people that I
see have a reason to go off the
reservation something that you guys
might not hurt but I did that
something's going on in their personal
life that along with comedy life spots
your agents your [ __ ] manager your
[ __ ] cousin that needs this
there's so many variables that there's
one thing that could push you over the
top that's why when I hear people
getting into trying to certain jams I
check in with them a couple days and I
check in with them again because I don't
want them to stray off the reservation
it's not you know I always make this an
expression it's not how many people you
shoot at we you shoot that work you know
if you live by the sword you die by the
sword you could just get so many knows
until you gotta know that pushes you
over the top you know when somebody's
shown us and get picked up but
somebody's show gets cancelled there's
little things that happen in this town
that we hear amongst each other that
could push a regular [ __ ] person over
the top I mean this is a hard life here
guys this is not for everybody they're
not giving out [ __ ] donations on the
Sunset Strip you know Hollywood is a
[ __ ] machine you ask yourself what
happened a few weeks ago with this Jesse
small like that he seems like a nice guy
I mean I'm paper you looking at means
it's [ __ ] sweetheart of a guy what
would make a guy do this I'm sure then
Jesse small that sat in your kitchen and
talked to you you smoked a joint with
him or whatever
he'd be a nice guy what would make Jesse
Smollett do something like this you know
what makes women want to suck your dick
for a [ __ ] movie or a guy the
Hollywood machine plays with your mind
whether it's music whether it's you know
[ __ ] comedy whether it's film
you know we're reading more and more now
of every week every other week somebody
else took their life last week a
musician for the Landy's or something so
this is something that could be
medication based I don't [ __ ] know I
don't have the [ __ ] answers I don't
have the answers to this all I know is
that you know tonight I have to go say
goodbye to this [ __ ] kid
I feel terrible because you guys you
guys saw me sit across from Lynne and
listen you know let's get something
[ __ ] straight you know I love doing
this podcast but there's certain people
are coming in and they're my family
and you could feel it in the podcast
it's not an interview it's a
conversation you guys even know when
it's conversation amongst good friends
you guys have said it to me well I've
had Ralphie in here or Rogen my
relationship but Rogen there's just
certain people that people mesh with you
know you guys know I love Brody Stevens
you know it I had him on the show every
time I saw my game a big hug I knew him
from 1995 and I didn't know about the
struggles till a couple of years ago and
after that I think after that we brought
him up to the show up there after the
struggles and I was breaking his balls I
shy so I'm checking you for weapons then
we were laughing and the whole thing I
mean Brody had a great sense of humor
you know so I just I'm really sorry if
you guys think that I was uh you know I
put a bunch of girls on hearing a bunch
of guys I did not want to come on this
podcast and drag the Brody Stevens saga
Hanyu you had seen it enough on the
internet how ideas have felt it I felt
your support you know what I feel like
and a lot of you guys have you know
anything about me I [ __ ] sweep that
[ __ ] on the rug I sweep that [ __ ] on the
rug because I got a job to do you know
Sam Tripoli is not over it red bands
down over it there are so many people
right now I talked and I've been calling
a lot of people Theo there's a lot of
different people that rock and rolling
with it but at the same time there's a
lot of people have been struggling what
a lot of the waitresses at the store are
the staff you know I know the talent
coordinators having a hard time with it
and tonight it all comes to it I didn't
want you guys to ever think that I
avoided Brody no no no no no it was just
too soon it was just too soon and it was
all over the Internet and
wanna dig into it now a little wait I
wanted to wait and see how I really felt
I didn't want to come on here with me
and Josh would think you're doing a
podcast that Sunday night I'm happy with
it because we would've came on here and
we both would have been a [ __ ] crime
mess you know I'm gonna go that tonight
I'm gonna speak my mind and I hope Brody
rest in peace I hope that you know I
mean it's a Catholic I'm raised to
believe a ton of stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] but
I don't I hope his soul was resting I
hope his soul looks down on us and sees
how many people are hurting but he did
this you know I mean you always try to
had some human face I can just imagine
brownie right now how you doing with God
like I want to go back here I want to go
to opening day you know I made a [ __ ]
mistake that's what I saw cuz I had
known Brody for a few years but to me
what I saw was that because what I would
imagine is that he didn't think that a
people wouldn't care or he thought maybe
he was doing people a favor and everyone
from like the Chicago Cubs to say actors
and comedians had nothing but positive
loving things to say about him and I
what I think is what I'm hoping is he
just didn't realize it and I'm hoping
that people what you were saying earlier
call a friend is I think that's what
happens is people think Oh it'll be
better for everyone if I'm gone or no
one will care hopefully if I have
anything good can come from what
happened to Brody is that even people we
there's someone who cares even if you
feel like you have nobody there's one
person who will be upset that you're
gone I just wish you would have reached
out you know I wish you would've reached
out to somebody like he had so many
people he could have called he had just
done a few
cast that week and nobody saw nothing
this is why this is so hard this is why
this grieving process is gonna be so
hard because nobody [ __ ] saw it
coming listen Ari once told me that
every time he saw a Ralphie
he would always hug him really hard
because he always thought but that'd be
the last time he saw a Ralphie as as
[ __ ] up as that sounds I think the
last three times we saw a Ralphie we
when he left here we were like he
doesn't look good he's getting bigger
you know whatever
I didn't see no warning signs of brownie
at all guys for not in the air of any
that's was kind of so all [ __ ] up that
nobody yeah you will know if the
medication I don't [ __ ] know anything
about this now I've investigated it but
I guys I'm sorry I just did not even see
this not even a hint of it let me tell
you something I can't mention their
names but I could see three comics that
you guys know kill themselves before
Brody in my world I worry about two
other comics in life then I worried more
about Brody that's why it shocked me
more like if somebody would call me and
say doctor that killed himself I've seen
it coming over the last couple of years
he's been struggling with it he's been
struggling when alcoholism or whatever
with Brody he gave us no hints guys
again he sat here in this chair across
from me less than two months ago you
guys saw not one of you guys had me back
on Twitter and said Joey
Brody it'll look good on your [ __ ]
podcast and it got close to I don't know
how many hits on YouTube so none of us
[ __ ] saw it so you know blame blame
blame I would love to be one of those
people that can say that you know
I couldn't change his mind nobody had
changed his [ __ ] mind that's why
those last 10 minutes the ones that
[ __ ] destroy me whether it was Brody
whether it was Chris Cornell whether it
was down the saying that killed himself
those last 10 minutes when your mind
just goes left and keeps pushing and
pushing and pushing and pushing and
pushing
you know like I'm saying to you guys let
me call three girls you're horny you're
drunk you're pushing your push and
you're pushing you but at one point you
go it's not gonna happen let me just
take my dick out whack it off and nobody
didn't go to bed you wake up and all
three of them showed up they won't you
know I'm saying it's one of those things
those last 10 minutes or what destroyed
me about Brody
you know every time you lose somebody
you lose a little piece of yourself I'm
telling you this at the age of 56 that
every one of my friends death has taken
I'm not gonna say I can't live without
that's [ __ ] but a little piece it
makes you learn it makes you stop and
smell the roses a little bit you know
when Ralphie died immediately [ __ ]
looked at my life and I looked at my
time and the one thing I would notice
about Ralphie was his waste of time like
the time he had all this time and you
know I started doing more with my time
if I learn anything from Brody is that
I'm really really really gonna look at
myself because I'm very scared I'm very
[ __ ] scared
I'm very scared that that could happen
to any of us in the comedy community
where your mind just takes a left turn
and keeps going and keeps going like I
said when I was younger and my mom died
I was trying to kill myself with the
drugs but not really like if I happen to
die I would have died nobody would he
gave a [ __ ] it was an OD
and I will we thought about you know I
[ __ ] killing myself that night when I
was 16 but my mind didn't keep going
somewhere along the line something
[ __ ] stop me it leave wasn't thinking
that people love me I think there was a
warmth that was greater than that it
wasn't honest to god it had nothing to
do with my friends at that time or
anything I didn't give a [ __ ] I just
thought that there was something greater
that stopped me and then it made me live
another [ __ ] day and I never thought
about it again I've never been suicidal
since that time again and I wasn't even
really suicidal then it was just a
thought that went through your mind when
that door goes through your mind that's
you know and it's gone through all of
our minds at one time or no I know it
has we're all human beings but you all
think what if what if you know no you
know God has an expiration day for all
you could do is live it out whether you
go out from a [ __ ] disease old age or
dementia we got a three year 36,000 mile
warranty my friend I think when you're
about 36 things start falling apart
loosening you start to see them all I
want to do is you know you guys to when
you get a minute today at some point
stop think about your lives and maybe
say a prayer for [ __ ] Brody Stevens
and they're gonna do a live stream
tonight from The Comedy Store if you
guys want to watch and I think you'd go
on Twitter and just look around all day
today there'll be different things but
they're gonna do a live streaming you
guys want to watch it they gonna
livestream the main room event and
they're gonna livestream the belly room
event and then a bunch of us going down
there I think that starts at 7:30 and
they're gonna do some the families when
they show up they're gonna play Brody's
special I'm gonna go down there brought
9c some people give us some hugs and I'm
gonna tell them what I'm gonna tell you
okay and here it is the nutshell I want
you to get three
[ __ ] friends I know a lot is whether
one of them was your cousin a girl at
work that you're friendly with and you
don't want men start checking in with
them you know start checking them with
them just practice practice calling
people and not ask him for something we
only call people when we want something
or we want them to do something for us
or something try calling somebody I'm
just saying hello and ask him about that
day try to do that from now on do me
that favor along with your goals okay
you'll do your goals but on top of that
I want you to physically pick up the
[ __ ] phone dial the number and listen
to that person's voice there's a reason
why I call people there's a reason why I
hate text messaging there's a reason if
you give a [ __ ] about me and I give a
[ __ ] about you and you're having a rough
day
I could tell by listening to your voice
that is the reason why I call people so
I'm gonna tell them tomorrow night the
same thing I'm telling you make three
people in your [ __ ] life and check in
with them and if you hear one of your
friends is going through a rough patch
check in with them you don't need to
take him for a beer you don't need to
show up with an expensive gift you don't
even know that stuff you have no idea
what the miracle of a phone call could
do the miracle of a [ __ ] phone call
how are you doing I know you're going
through a [ __ ] rough patch and trust
me there's a thousand people I could
call every day and I try to call three
or one or two I try to do one a day
check in with people if you see people
are going astray a little bit check in
with them again you don't have to stick
your [ __ ] nose up their ass but
checking in with them you don't you know
what I do with the people I check it
with them late at night to really [ __ ]
with you I check in with you because why
if I learned something from my mother if
I learned something from me the pain
stretch
creeping in when you're alone at night
all day long when you're doing your [ __ ]
pop it up pop it up pop and you [ __ ]
and you're telling your stories about
the time you went the [ __ ] in Egypt and
you smoked hashish with this [ __ ] do
from Poland and whatever the [ __ ] all
that shit's great that's what keeps your
mind occupied it's when you go home at
night I call cane at night I call Silvan
sometimes 11:30 at night
I'll call Aria [ __ ] 2:00 in the
morning I'll get up at 1:00 just to call
Ari at 4:00 and go now I don't know cuz
he's getting a girlfriend he's moving in
with her in April so I really can't call
him late at night I will call him with
people at that time because my uncle
I'll call my uncle [ __ ] 11:30 at
night because you're alone you're alone
with your thoughts this is when you
could either win or lose when you're
alone with your thoughts all day long
world were stimulated by the Internet
the [ __ ] cell phone this that it's
when we're alone that we're almost
dangerous I know I'm the most dangerous
and I'm [ __ ] alone when I'm alone
Jesus Christ that's what my mom wand is
that's where you might take that [ __ ]
thing that you've been saving in the
closet you might take a hit of that
thing you've been saving the clock
whatever just do me a favor take two
people three people in your life just
start checking in with them I really
want to get this podcast out of the way
because I know you guys been waiting on
my take and I want to let you know how I
feel like I said I want to think about
it first before I just raised my hand on
here I didn't want to do a [ __ ] group
grow podcast I wanted to talk to you
about how I fell from the heart and
listen man yeah a little bit of mirrors
hurtin well guess what I got a job to
know I got mouths to feed and we all
need each other you know and I think
that the more we look after our friends
the less these type of situations will
happen in our backyard I want to
dedicate this podcast to Brody
I want to thank you guys for listening
again
to drag a dog in here on you will be
back Wednesday [ __ ] smoking pot doing
drugs and giggling and all that [ __ ] but
today Monday I want to open up this pot
this week with this because tonight's
the memorial and uh it was just
important for me to do this podcast I
want to thank the people who came up to
all the shows in Houston this last
weekend but I also want to thank my
sponsors number one zip recruiter let me
tell you some hiring is challenging but
there's one place you can go where
hiring is simple fast and smart a place
where growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates that place is zip
recruited calm slash Church listen
hiring used to be hard multiple job
sites a stack of resumes confusing
review process but today hiring is easy
and it's simple and smart with zip
recruited comm Y as applications come in
zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match the zipper
Coonan is so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter will
get a quality candidate through the site
within the first day zip recruiter sends
your job to over a hundred of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there so do me a favor right now today
the church family can try zip recruiter
for free at SIP recruited comm slash
Church that CH you are CH zip recruited
Thomas last Church right now you I don't
care how small how big your business is
if you're a family of the church you
could try out zip recruiter for free
free free free gonna zip recruiter comm
slash Church CH you are CH that's zip
recruiter comm slash Church [ __ ] look
at March Madness is here [ __ ]
lift the rock brackets first-round
upsets it's the final four now this is
the best time to bet with my bookie
would you rather sit on your office desk
or call out sick and
Jhansi double-a tournament games and
junk food like that's even a [ __ ]
choice but sometimes it feels good to be
bad especially when it's in some way
with someone you trust now if you're
looking at a place of bet this [ __ ]
much man this season you doing it
through [ __ ] my bookie dot eg is it
daddy G a G I'm sorry you know I forgot
the [ __ ] reefers get to me they've
been in business for years and they've
been growing like wildfire
alright the best part is they pay out
fast so when you call that 12 over 5
upset this year make sure to celebrate
you'll be pocketing cold hard
[ __ ] cash March Madness is the
most exciting action-packed sporting
event of the year even grandmothers
[ __ ] fill out the brackets so do me a
favor if you're gonna place a bet place
it with my bookie
now before you miss out what I'm gonna
do for you is this for March Madness my
bookie will match your deposit with a
50% bonus up to $1,000 Joey what are you
saying you put in for a thousand bucks
they put it in an echo how's that for
you use promo code Church CH you are CH
to activate the offer visit my bookie
dot AG Tay you play you win you get paid
like a [ __ ] only at my bookie
dot AG okay listen you got a bet anyway
if you're gonna bet that with the best
that's out there go to my bookie dot AG
I want to take my bookie I don't want to
TechSoup recruiter most importantly I
want to thank you guys for supporting
the podcast and whatnot do me a big
favor three shows are sold out the
Pittsburgh improv already if you're
gonna get your tickets get your tickets
I'm there between March 4th and the six
I think Saturday is all sold out and
Friday late sold out I might have had a
Thursday show I'm not sure yet because I
can't get a [ __ ] direct way number
two for 19 fitzgerald either celebrating
three for twenty and then for twenty I'm
at the Pabst [ __ ] Theatre in
Milwaukee how's that for you [ __ ]
that's all I got coming up that said
it's a slow month I'm doing some other
things
but most importantly we're doing it
[ __ ] right I love you guys thank you
for this podcast today I want to
dedicate it to brother Stevens I wish
she rests in peace and as you guys know
we're all gonna miss him here on the
church podcast I'll see you guys
Wednesday tip top Magoo ready the
[ __ ] go chick this really